[Musica]
play the game
[Applauso]
[Musica]
michele a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono farmi j
ed oggi siamo tornati dopo mesi sul
surge e un simulator non credevo che
potessero fare un altro gli lcd sta roba
ovviamente racconto è uscito il dlc me
l'avete giustamente segnalati in 450mila
persone comunque ragazzi per bloccarmi
sta cosa dell'alieno mia mi sento che
devo andare allora nello spazio chi qui
c'era arrivato già perché la moglie ha
fatto il trapianto nello spazio
devo trovare un tastierino 8 ae ha detto
vecchio perfetto trovato fuori dal caso
90 trovato il tastierino numerico devi
mettere le seguenti cifre allora due
alternative che devo mettere il dito
meglio ovviamente ragazzi seno non
funziona c'è una pastiglia che volano
non me la infilo 2 oggi ha sbagliato
all'inizio 961 no no 144 44 madonna
santissima devi premere di fottuti tasti
ma quando fai i numeri di telefono come
cazzo fai qua 5 cc ragazzi sì sì ce l'ho
fatta
mi chiamo impresa titanica inserisci il
codice è sorretta mica ci ha messo
un'ora e mezza va bene allora ce l'ho ce
l'ho fatta che cazzo succede
raga
ok ragazzi e se per caso
guardate fuori dalla finestra e vedere
cadere un po dj dal cielo sapete perché
fermi rappresentato dall altro episodio
di guerre stellari non lo so ok la
cassetta ragazzo ha sbloccato la
cassetta cc dovremmo essere ragazzi
prima operazione dopo secoli vi voglio
carichissimi nello spazio o mancato
completamente cioè non la mano va la
cassetta ragazzi sto gioco mi sta dando
suonarvi peggio di cat mario ve lo dico
sì mio zio stata un'impresa assurda ci
fosse un quarto 49 48
devo chiamarlo sto numero 4 chi cazzo è
la devo scusare presumo che comunque
debba inserire il codice quello che ho
visto allo schermo tipo 4 che cazzo era
49 48 o 48 49 uno dei due
ok per feci siamo 49 48 perfetto adesso
cosa facciamo
decolla adesso si spacca tutto il nuovo
siamo al diavolo la direttiva primari ok
buongiorno mi presento sono dottor fa vj
piacere di conoscerti amico mio comando
signò co amico mio non so di chi avendo
sicuro stai calmo allora ragazzi
dobbiamo cos'è cazzo ci fa uno show a ok
perfetto questo no dio
oddio ragazzi come questo epico il cazzo
se l'è inventato altra cosa come potete
notare ragazzi il paziente ha una terza
mano all'interno dello stomaco mai
dobbiamo aveva una calza mano
all'interno dello stomaco comunque una
volta rimossa la terza ragazzi si può
procedere a recidere queste cose blu che
noi da di che cazzo siano però si
tolgono perché è più figo senza bene
così eh si si mangia tutto ciò che ci
sei bravo così i ragazzi di heathrow che
siete attratti tutti nel suo braccio
sexy guardate che gli occhi ragazzi io
se devo essere sincero non ho neanche
capito bene che cosa devo fare sto tizio
marameo lo poi a tua sorella brutto
stronzo credo che i ragazzi che ne che
segue l'affare che luccica di sotto
quello nero devo devo togliere quella
fare né questo qui questo nero sinistra
credo ma non so come cazzo toglierlo
ragazzi credo che sia quello a fare nero
ma se devo essere sincera non ne sono
completamente sicuro comunque noi
proviamo attorno al sito come si toglie
ma se lo faremo va in auto distruzione
che cazzo fai toglimi le mani di dosso
lurido ragazzi allora la prima regola è
non toccare il dottore sai dove tele il
filo stamani e non meglio che non lo
sappia allora devo devo levare scappare
nero credo non lo so sono diventato
bravissimo elementari a furia di
tagliare i pezzi di carta la dovrei fare
l'ho fatta ma non ce l'ho non ce l'ha
fatta una dizione ragazza posso fare nè
difficile dio mio
ho preso scorso ma che cazzo ci guiderà
ga e voi non lo sapete ma se adesso vado
a destra col mouse viva si sono
invertiti comandi praticamente un
dottore non può lavorare così ce l'ha
fatta a togliersi ce l'ho tolto lottato
ma è morto adesso ma [ __ ] una
[ __ ] e ore di operazione andati a
[ __ ] grazie mille
senti se ci facevi cazzi tua ethos tema
nile tenevi ferme a quest'ora avevamo
finito è colpa tua non ti lamentare
brutto stronzo chi cazzo di alieni che
al giorno d'oggi non collaborano neanche
li lascerei morire tutti e credetemi che
non sono razzista contro gli alieni ma
sono loro che mi danno segnarvi
maledizione deve riuscire a tagliare
allora dategli un [ __ ] bitri ce ne
sono 47 se non riuscite col bisturi
andateci un po più sul pesante ma
togliete sta merda ragazzi non si toglie
c'è impossibile mi serve qualcuno c'è un
bazooka
cioè non perché se consiglio così beh
vabbè dai mi capita così che cazzo vuoi
ti scateno contro godzilla il capolista
scatole più sottile di quello del mio
mouse come fanno impazzire
se alla fine l'unica stronza e adesso
poi ingoiarla direttamente fi cos'è va
bene l'occhio la stessa cosa non importa
ragazzi comunque una volta tolta la
scatola ci dovremmo essere praticamente
dovevo sostituirla
datemi un ascia fatevi la [ __ ] ascia
ci porta posto ma ragazzi lasciano
iniziato sfracellando tutto aspetta
scassate solite sì ce la posso fare
una volta tanto la scatola ragazzi
scassate tutto e prendete quella nuova
se riuscite sempre cioè la dovrei aver
fatto si è infine ragazzi una volta
presa la scatola finale
dovete reinserire nel punto di prima
dovrei dovresti dire se si è mio zio è
stato ho preso anche alla lode ragazzi
ovviamente la date voi quindi se
ritenete che l'america in estate mi
piace è quella che vale come lode
praticamente è stata una cosa assurda
che un cast in effetti lo riavviata più
volte perché ho perso 350 mila volte ci
sono il sito una che appunto questa
comunque
qui vito ragazzi se usciranno altri
villaggi ovviamente leandro appare
perché è stato sì muretto e sempre epico
quindi ragazze video è piaciuto come al
solito lasciando un commento mi piace
anche la pace di facebook e come non
divido fate nella descrizione
iscrivetevi rivediamolo proseguito bella
ragazzi